On the last 13 seconds.
Volkov yeah,
I think he has a sting ray.
I thought I was like,
Oh yeah.
It is kind of a sting.
I could see you going like what a great friend to stewards are.
Some of the most underrated to creatures there are.
First of all,
the preschoolers should haven't evolved in millions and millions of years.
We're strange thing to have tattoo on your back and wonder if he's like an ocean
guy.
Really
did sit oh gee,
shit.
Ice.
We swam with those and,
and uh,
forget where.
Oh,
Flores off Flores.
I near where the Komodo dragons are.
You fucking dive in and restore.
He went to the isle of Flora's.
Oh,
that's,
that's where that little fucking man lived.
You know,
they had that,
that human being that they found,
what did they call it?
Um,
Homo Floresiensis,
I think they call it.
Yeah.
It was a little tiny hobbit,
like person that existed,
I want to say as recently as 10 to 15,000 years ago,
there was like a three foot tall kind of human.
Yeah.
There was,
there's been many different branches of human being,
right?
There's been neander tall homosapien.
There's a one from Russia,
Diane Isis or something like that.
I forget how to say like,
look at that.
Oh yeah,
no,
I met that guy.
He ran a hustle.
I stood up.
Yeah,
that guy was the shit he gave me.
Good,
good drugs.
Um,
but this little little person that lived alongside human beings,
see if my timeline is right.
They have speech they don't know,
but they know they use tools.
I don't know am I was make sure to paint them with tool to show you what I need.
Five thousand seventy thousand years ago.
Oh,
that's it.
17,000 years ago.
Wow.
Why does it say he bunked but what's that one?
Hobbit.
Human species debunked.
I don't think that's correct.
It says new historian,
but uh,
I'm pretty sure that's probably an old article.
Audiences.
What year?
What was that article?
When is that?
10 years ago.
10 years ago?
Yeah.
Was it 10 years ago?
2004 Oh,
no,
no.
The talking about it.
I'm sorry.
So it's 2014 is the article.
That's fairly recently.
I don't think that's the consensus.
I don't think the consensus is that it's been debunked.
Part is about the cranial volume.
Oh brain size,
I guess,
but not that it was a separate species.
Cranium volume was calculated to be foreign in 30 million liters milliliters,
which puts it within the range of modern human living in the same region.
They went further comparing the size of the circumference of the Occipital,
said the word I said,
little frontal section of the skull to patients with developmental disorders in
that region.
The planet,
they found the measurements were indeed similar.
If lb one did have down syndrome,
then it would explain this short femurs as well.
Hence when calculated statistically for normal growth,
they would yield a height of just over four feet,
which matches up with some humans living on Flores.
Wow.
Hmm.
This is,
I think this is probably one of those heavily debated things,
but you're trying to recreate,
you know,
there's a thing called island dwarfism that happens too.
Um,
it's,
it's a really odd,
because it happens to mammals,
but the opposite takes place with lizards and reptile.
Massive.
Yeah.
Reptiles get massive like Komodo dragons on the island.
The Komodo,
scariest.
Fun of giant.
They get huge monitor lizards really essentially that are enormous.
Whereas elephants that live on islands get tiny.
They have these dwarf elephants.
Yeah.
See that island morphis room to have to cover so no less resources.
So they adapt to the taxes.
Less food.
Like look how tiny that elephant is that lives on those.
I mean it's an elephant that's like shorter than you wow.
And elephants through.
Yeah.
It's,
look,
that's like a elephant.
That's like my kid's height.
Like this is,
it happens with all sorts of different animals.
He Dwarf Buffalo.
Yeah.
Island dwarfism.
They think it's because these animals adapt to the fact that there's just a
limited amount of living on a territory.
Right.
They don't have to cover long distances to get to something.
Yeah.
It's fucking crazy.
What happens with animals,
man,
when they figure out like what they need to do to survive.
Like one of the things that a I was reading about really recently was,
um,
these,
fuck,
I wish I had it off the top of my head,
but these moths that lived in a separate area,
an area where things were darker and they change from a light colored moth to a
black moth,
like really quickly.
Really?
Yeah.
Like really quickly.
Like they did it over a couple of generations and they're trying to figure out
how the fuck this happened.
See if he could find that couple generations go false peppered moth.
Yeah.
Really fast.
Like it,
it blew them away.
They don't understand how it happened so quickly.
I think there's like,
there's,
there's so little that's truly understood about what adaptive changes can
possibly happen within animals.